Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Connors. Again, we're going to do a quick video just to help understand
aqua genes, tumor aqua genes, and tumor suppressor genes. You know, it's obviously a more information
that we can share in a video this size, but just to give you more little hints, so we understand what
we're talking about. So we talk about aqua genes, and then there's other genes that are called
proto-alco genes. We're talking about genes that stimulate cancer growth, that increase cancer
growth, versus tumor suppressor genes, tumor suppressor genes, due to just that, they suppress cancer
growth. So as we go through this, I hope you'll understand it a little bit better. So when we look
at a normal cell, very confusing picture here, but just look at my cursor here, look at a normal cell,
a normal cell stays a functioning normal cell, and we look at this piece here, this is called a cell
cycle. Cells aren't always going through this cell cycle. A normal cell is in a state where it's
functioning as a cell. So let's pretend this is a liver cell. So this is functioning as a liver cell,
and it's doing its liver cell things. So it's acting out whatever that cell in that tissue is supposed
to do. A liver cell, it's a big part of the detoxification piece and helping you detoxify things, etc.
Lever does hundreds and hundreds of different functions. That's in a phase called the G O phase.
The G zero phase is how a cell is just functioning normally as it's cell. This is the cell cycle.
What a cell is undergoing, it's getting ready to undergo replication. The normally a liver cell
goes through the cell cycle about the average about once every 12 weeks. The purpose is to renew
itself and to make another cell so that the mother cell we could say that will pass away and go
through apoptosis. Your body gets rid of it so that you're always trying to reserve itself,
recycle itself, and make a better self to stay functioning as a human being. So normal cells will
stay in this G zero phase for a period of time. Sound different cells will stay in that G zero phase,
basically a person's whole life. And then when it goes through this cell cycle of replication,
there's different checkpoints along this cycle to prevent excess replication. So in this picture,
it's showing excessive growth. This would be a cancer. So this is not supposed to take place.
And the way our body has preventative mechanism to not have cancer take place is through these different
checkpoints through the cell cycle, a replication phase of bytosis. So a normal cell goes through into
this G one phase and there's certain proteins and enzymes that stimulate this cell cycle phase for
G one to go into the S phase, the G two phase and the M phase. This is bytosis where replication takes
place. So two cells are produced from this one cell. It turns into two cells and the mother cell then
passes away, goes through apoptosis, leaves it a cell left. That will stay in the G zero phase, hopefully.
Until 12 weeks later, it goes into cell replication again. It replicates itself. The mother cell goes
through apoptosis. The daughter still stays at a GO phase for 12 weeks, functions in that cell functioning
measure. And then we'll go through this again every 12 weeks. So it's never in a perfect timing like
this, but you could say your liver is renewed four times a year, baby. The problem comes in is when
a cell is damaged, going through this phase, and it is able to bypass the checkpoints and instead of
going into the GO phase and function as a normal cell, it continues through the cell replication cycle
and continues to reproduce and reproduce and reproduce. Now there's things that happen to a cell
that cause this. Poisons can get inside a cell and damage this mechanism and turn on certain
genes that then we call these genes, Uncle genes. There's several different genes that can be turned on
that we will then call Uncle genes, the RAS genes, the MYC genes. These are actually not
tuber-causing genes per se. These are genes that stimulate growth. So the Keras system,
that would be a RAS gene, is up-regulated or increased in case of when I have to heal a wound per se.
So when I have to heal a wound, I have to make a lot of new cells
in order to heal and scar over that wound. So during a period of trauma, I got into car accident
and I have a bunch of wounds all over me, my normal cell will be kicked in through the Keras system,
through the RAS gene system, that would up-regulate mitosis and my cells will undergo a process of
reproduction over and over again in order to heal that wound. And I would be congratulated for being
a fast healer and I'm out in the hospital at no time because my wounds were healed and this is
a wonderful thing. So don't always think that up-regulation of the Keras system is a bad thing.
In the case of wound healing, it would be a good thing. In the case of no wound healing is necessary
and a damaged Keras gene or a defector mutation on a Keras gene would up-regulate that growth phase
that would be bad in a case of cancer. So now a cancer gene has up-regulated or damaged or
mutated Keras genes, then it's going to stimulate this process and help propagate a cancer.
So people with cancer looking at these different oncogenes and if the person has mutations or defects
of these oncogenes, it would be good to know because there are some things that we could do to step
in to help decrease that. There are some dietary concerns that we could step in to help
to help slow down the Keras system and the NYC gene system. So these are considered oncogenes in a
cancer. They are things that increase the cell cycle replication of cells. Again,
everything in the body, we don't want to label it a good thing or a bad thing, it's only good
advantage certain circumstances. So in a cancer, an up-regulated Keras system,
someone with a lot of mutations on the Keras genes, not good to have cancer. So it's going to
stimulate cancer growth. The other way that our body protects against cancer growth is what's
called a tumor suppressor gene. So there's certain genes that help with these checkpoints. So they
look at a cell and see if it's damaged. And if it is damaged, those tumor suppressor genes
kick in so that a cell won't go through this process of replication. So if a normal cell
gets into the cell cycle and our body recognizes that cell is having damaged genes,
then these different checkpoints here should block the replication. And the replication never
occurs. And eventually this cell goes through apoptosis. That's our body. Killing it or recycling it
or breaking it down and re-utilizing the cell components. So these are called tumor suppressor
genes or our tumor suppressor system. So our tumor suppressor system blocks the cell replication.
It helps arrest cell function, cell growth function. So P53 is probably the first discovered
tumor suppressor gene. And there's much written about that. So that's an example of a tumor suppressor
gene that recognizes the mutation that P53 gene is turned on. P53 gene releases certain enzymes
into the cell and it can cause an arrest of this replication cycle. So that cell doesn't go through
replication. It will later help stimulate apoptosis or cell death of that cell.
Or it can actually help repair damaged DNA so that that cell can go back into the geofase and
function as a normally functioning cell. And if it can't, then it will stimulate apoptosis. So
the tumor suppressor system is very, very important. So where we see cancer occurring is where the
tumor suppressor genes are, quote unquote, turned off or hyperbethylated. And the tumor
oncogenes are turned on or acetylated or unbethylated. That's where we have issues or we have an
up-regulation of tumor oncogenes and a down-regulation of tumor suppressor genes. And that's what's
measured in tests like the IVG test. We look at free circulating cell DNA,
circulating tumor cells and look at what's the percentage of the oncogenes that are up-regulated
and the tumor suppressor genes are down-regulated because that would increase, that would tell us that
there's a more aggressive cancer going on. And that's really what gives us the indications.
The more aggressive cancer we have, the more oncogenes are turned on and the more tumor
gene suppressor genes are turned off. So we want to make intervention by stimulating tumor suppressor
gene up-regulation because we want those suppressing the tumor. And we want to make intervention by
down-regulating the tumor oncogenes. So hopefully this makes a little bit more sense. We want our
tumor suppressor genes working. We want to turn off our tumor oncogenes. There's a bunch of natural
things that will stimulate tumor oncogenes. Those are growth factors. And there's a bunch of natural
things, stimulators, of tumor suppressor genes. So it's important to know those things and that's
what we go through in a lot of our other videos. So hopefully this little diagram gives us a little
bit better understanding of tumor oncogenes, tumor suppressor genes, cell cycle how that works, how our
body has protective measures and how those protective measures can break down. All right, Dr. Kevin
Cutters, thank you very much.